trump's triumphs that's the focus
of tonight's angle as i close out this
year
i thought it was super important to
reiterate just how
fortunate we were to have had a
president like donald trump for four
years
now forget the savagery of his critics
the rank
media bias and of course the controversy
surrounding the 2020 election mail on
ballots
set that aside for just a moment and
just focus
on what president trump against
incredibly strong headwinds
did for our economy today more than
six weeks after election day the new
york times believe it or not published a
piece confirming
how much trump's policies helped our
factory workers
the focus in that article was on the
carrier plan in indianapolis
now it seems like a lifetime ago when in
february 2016
a carrier executive made an announcement
about the fate of the storied
became clear enterprise the best way to
stay competitive
and protect the business for long term
is to move production
from our facility in indianapolis
to monterey mexico
but then populist pro-american worker
donald trump
made it his personal mission after he
won the presidency
to ensure that carriers save these
american jobs
and keep its factory in the united
states
indiana is the home of carrier air
conditioning which is leaving from
mexico
that won't happen if i'm president
carrier will not be leaving indiana if
i'm president you are one of the people
whose jobs was saved
yes yes do you thank donald trump for
this yes
yes did you ever think it would happen
no
even on thanksgiving when when we heard
that there was a tweet that
carrick donald was talking to carrier i
was like no
we've already started taking
measurements they're gone
and there's no way no way
but yeah he did it oh my gosh i watch
that it makes me want to cry
now almost five years later its workers
are logging long days
and the plant is thriving but
with globalist joe biden waiting in the
wings the workers now have a foreboding
feeling
about what the future will hold some of
us think they're stockpiling equipment
so they can close the factory later
that's a worry that has only intensified
for workers like paul roell
a trump supporter who fears that after
the president leaves office
carrier management will dust off old
plans to move the factories
1050 jobs to mexico
trump's the reason we have our job and
as long as he was in office
we were safe mr rawls said we don't have
the leverage anymore
well i'm sorry to say uh the workers
there they're instinct
it's spot on china and other low-wage
countries
including mexico they're licking their
chops eager to gobble up the last of our
great american factories
and with them good paying jobs they've
already gotten the eu
to agree in principle that china has to
a major investment agreement that was
just announced
and now they're acting aggressively
targeting against
australia with disproportionately
massive
tariffs leveled and levied by beijing
so if joe biden if he didn't want to
lose to china
he shouldn't have signaled that he had
every intention of trashing trump's
america first trade agenda
the eu well they've decided to throw in
with the global winner
and with trump out of the way that
winner is china
now in this scenario the rich
international conglomerates
they'll get richer wall street they'll
get a lot richer too
as they all engage in ruthless global
arbitrage without one
wit of concern when entire american
industries
are dismantled and shipped overseas
isn't globalization
wonderful you know that's what they're
gonna say they're gonna say look at all
these cheap products we have
toys are so cheap and you can buy a pair
of pants for you know four dollars
what a travesty biden will merely be a
passive manager of our decline as we
outsource
not just jobs but our entire future
but back to trump's triumphs this week's
stunning economic news from the federal
reserve
that was completely lost or ignored by
the lame stream press
i'm talking about the fed's projections
for the u.s economy
which in convenient timing exceed its
projections
from just a few months ago as the fall
campaign season got underway
now we find on page two of this document
that the change in real gdp
for 2020 is now projected to be negative
2.4 percent
that's an improvement from the
prediction of negative 3.7
in september in other words what will be
an economic disaster for much of the
world including europe
will be only a mild recession for
americans under trump
trump the republican governors who kept
things open and the american people
saved the u.s economy and the
unemployment rate for 2020 is projected
to be 6.7 percent
that's an improvement from the 7.6
percent
they were predicting back in september
again this figure
would be much worse if we had listened
to team
lockdown the fed projects a booming
economy over the next two years
4.2 percent growth in 2021 and
the 2023 unemployment rate should be
down
they say to 3.7 percent
in short president trump has effectively
solved the problems created by the
pandemic
he said would develop a vaccine by the
end of the year and we did
he said would ensure that that cure
wasn't worse than the disease
and looks like he did that too he's left
biden with vaccines and an economy that
is set
to boom if that boom doesn't happen
we're all gonna know who's to blame now
it's odd that all these numbers these
revised projections they got so much
better after the election
isn't that weird now it might it have
been
nice for us i think so the voting public
to have known these
incredible facts and revised numbers
before the election
you bet but we know how the media
operates highlight
any and all developments that could have
a negative impact on the president
and bury the good news that reveal just
how difficult
life would become for regular people
regular working people
once again under joe biden yeah we're
going to be building back better all
right but unfortunately
it will be happening in china not here
certainly not in places like
indianapolis
where i'm afraid that carrier plants
days are numbered
and to all of you georgians you're
getting ready to vote maybe you already
have
in those senate runoff races you all
should be asking yourself
which senators will be more likely to
support
policies that make it harder to ship
jobs manufacturing jobs overseas
and which senators will make it easier
to do so
also which senators will work to
preserve all other good paying jobs
including
those that relate to the oil and gas
industry
well i think you know the answer
and tonight i want to say thank you to
president trump
for what you did for the forgotten man
and woman across this country and for
american industry
and also for the families that don't
want handouts
they want a government that works for
them they want the dignity
of decent wages for a full day's work
the last four years are a prime example
of what a president
should be doing for the people you may
be brash at times and the liberals don't
like that mr president
but you've got things done you put
america first
and that is what's truly important
merry christmas to all of you and merry
christmas to the entire trump family for
what they sacrificed
over the last four years and that's the
angle